[Música]
[Aplausos]
globalización y competencias
dos palabras que han acompañado a la
humanidad durante siglos y que están
aquí entre nosotros cuántos de ustedes
tienen en este momento un teléfono
celular con acceso a internet pues
pueden ante la mano
todos según un informe de cisco networks
para el 2023 habrá 5.3 millones de
usuarios de dispositivos móviles con
acceso a internet
eso es el 70% de la población mundial y
esto habla de lo mucho que ha crecido y
lo profundo que ha llegado la
globalización en su sinergia la
globalización y las competencias han
formado la realidad que vivimos hoy en
el mundo estuvieron presentes cuando los
primeros exploradores descubrieron las
diferentes partes del mundo estuvieron
presentes cuando fueron las revoluciones
industriales y están presentes hoy con
nosotros actualmente muchas personas
sienten como ansiedad del presente pero
sobre todo del futuro en un mundo en
donde las cosas cambian tan rápido y de
manera tan masiva nos preguntamos si
seremos capaces de adaptarnos pero sobre
todo si seremos capaces de prosperar y
la evidencia demuestra que el entender
la sinergia entre la globalización y las
competencias nos puede ayudar a
desarrollar las capacidades para
enfrentar cualquier situación que
vivamos en el presente o en el futuro
pero de eso hablaremos después
todos hemos escuchado la globalización y
tenemos por lo menos un concepto general
de ella en un principio se concibió como
el simple intercambio de mercancías de
un lado a otro del mundo
la empresa que empieza local y luego
estatal nacional internacional la gran
corporación multinacional pero la
globalización tiene diferentes
dimensiones y es un concepto que está en
constante evolución particularmente en
el 2021 viviendo los efectos de una
pandemia como es el kobe 19
cuando lo que sucedió en una pequeña
región del otro lado del mundo en china
afectó a todo el planeta afectó nuestra
forma de hacer las cosas y nuestra forma
de actuar cotidiana incluyendo esta
plática ted la cual si no hubiera habido
una pandemia tendrá una estructura
distinta entonces el tema de salud
global toma relevancia hoy pero también
el tema económico las empresas hoy están
más globalizadas que nunca antes y eso
lo vemos en nuestras casas donde
diariamente utilizamos servicios de
empresas globales por ejemplo vemos
películas netflix escuchamos música en
spotify
compramos libros en google books o en
amazon utilizamos google maps para
llegar a nuestros destinos cotidianos de
hecho les apuesto que no va a pasar más
de media hora sin que alguien de
nosotros compre un producto o un
servicio o simplemente una consulta en
una compañía global de internet
y nosotros también
hemos sido afectados por la
globalización a nivel personal hoy
estamos más globalizados que nunca y
saben que se nota mucho en la educación
y el conocimiento antes el nivel de
conocimiento dependía mucho del nivel
educativo que teníamos a más educación
más conocimientos hoy ya no es así hoy a
través de las tecnologías de la
información que le permiten a las
compañías alcanzarnos de manera
simultánea y prácticamente instantánea
también nos permiten a nosotros acceder
al conocimiento de cualquier parte del
mundo
entonces ya no es necesario cursar toda
la carrera la licenciatura de este
doctorado para llegar al conocimiento
del doctorado hoy a través de las
tecnologías de la información podemos
acceder a cualquier libro de cualquier
disciplina de cualquier nivel en
cualquier parte del mundo
de manera simultánea instantánea y
prácticamente gratuita entonces lo que
hoy nos diferencia unos de otros ya no
es lo que sabemos
lo que nos diferencia es lo que somos
capaces de hacer con lo que sabemos y es
ahí donde entran las competencias
yo tuve mi primer acercamiento con las
competencias hace 20 años más de 20 años
en parís cuando conocí a una persona que
me enseñó un montón él se llaman aigle
watts es un caballero inglés que me tocó
participar ponerla en una junta
internacional en francia y él es muy
respetado en las redes internacionales
por la cantidad de países que conoce de
repente nos preguntábamos si alguien lo
podía alcanzar y renunciamos cuando nos
dimos cuenta que pues el michael conoce
países que ya no existen
social conoció a checoslovaquia o es
república checa república de eslovaquia
entonces dijimos no nunca lo vamos a
alcanzar la cosa es que nos tocó salir
juntos de la reunión y caminar porque mi
hotel quedaba de camino de su estación
de tren que tiene que tomar para llegar
su destino ya vamos caminando con aire y
cuando llegamos a la estación de metro
no lo sabíamos en ese momento pero el
último tren ya se había ido porque
salimos tarde y se alargó la junta de
trabajo
cuando llegamos y lo vimos
a mí no me pasó pues que me quedara sin
tren pero a ver hay que pensar que el
2000 pues el 2000 no había celulares no
había internet no había uber no había
google man no había nada y a mí no me
pasó que me quedé sin tren y me dio un
pequeño ataque de pánico a mí yo dije en
otro país solo en el medio de la noche
sin medios de comunicación y sin
transporte pero en aigle con esa
tranquilidad que y esa precisión que
caracteriza a los ingleses el voltio y
vio el tablero y dijo
wow
pero nunca perdió la calma jamás se
despidió de mí nos despedimos yo seguí
caminando las últimas palabras que él me
dijo fue ahí siguió bueno y si yo te veo
cuando te vea
y ya después obviamente que se llegó a
su lugar llegó bien pues lo que a mí me
llamó la atención es cómo una persona
que
esta es una situación inesperada difícil
complicada desafiante estresante se las
arregla para reaccionar de manera
calmada no perder la calma no perder la
educación no perder la empatía y al
mismo tiempo encontrar una solución que
se tiene que tener para lograr eso
hoy la globalización también nos ha
cambiado diametralmente la forma en cómo
trabajamos quién de ustedes ha estudiado
y trabajado o una combinación de los dos
en línea ahora quién lo ha hecho
la mayoría de todos nosotros no la
pandemia vino a cambiar esto la
globalización
ha abierto nuevas posibilidades dentro
del mercado de trabajo y hay un concepto
bien interesante que se llama migración
digital la cual significa que podemos
trabajar para otro país sin dejar
nuestro país
hoy perfectamente o sea si ustedes
hicieron esta mecánica de trabajo en
línea y lo hicieron a nivel nacional que
les impide hacerlo a nivel internacional
cuál es el impedimento hoy un contador
en montenegro puede llevar la
contabilidad a una firma de abogados en
nueva york con la diferencia de que un
contador o nueva york cobraría 10 veces
más que en montenegro el de montenegro
puede cobrar la mitad sería la mitad de
costoso para nueva york pero aún así
ganaría 5 veces más que lo que ganaría
en su país
también sin irnos más lejos nosotros
como mexicanos por ejemplo pudiéramos
perfectamente ser maestros en línea de
español para una escuela que está fuera
del país
y cobrar desde otro país en méxico sin
salir de nuestra casa y sin migrar
físicamente
entonces si se pone ustedes a pensar la
migra es la admiración la globalización
hoy es una forma de redistribución
global de la riqueza la pregunta es cómo
accedemos porque eso es para las
personas que tienen las competencias
correctas entonces la pregunta sería
cuáles son las competencias y cómo las
desarrollamos
según un estudio del foro económico
mundial estas son las 10 competencias y
habilidades que necesitaremos a partir
del 2020 en los lugares de trabajo
flexibilidad cognitiva negociación
orientación al servicio juicio y toma de
decisiones inteligencia emocional
trabajo en equipo y coordinación con los
demás manejo de personas
creatividad
pensamiento crítico
resolución de problemas complejos y
porque son importantes estas
competencias según la organización
mundial del trabajo es por esto para las
personas son importantes porque el tener
las competencias correctas te permite
tener éxito ser más productivo y
construir una carrera
y para las empresas y mejorar tu vida
obviamente y para las empresas que tener
personas con las competencias correctas
les permite innovar adaptarse a nuevas
tecnologías atraer inversiones crear
trabajos competir en nuevos mercados y
desarrollar productos y servicios de
valor para el mercado global pero esto
que de repente nos pareciera como unos
temas como muy económicos y muy este del
mercado laboral curiosamente nos
reflejan algo bien profundo de nuestra
naturaleza humana y saber en qué se ve
muy claramente en el sistema educativo
todos sabemos que el sistema educativo
moderno se vio influenciado por las
revoluciones industriales más o menos
como del 1800 para acá la primera
revolución industrial del vapor la
segunda la electricidad la tercera la
informática entonces en estas
revoluciones industriales se necesitaba
un trabajo especializado
repetitivo de manejo de datos y de
seguir órdenes por lo tanto el sistema
educativo nos enseñó
ah
y aprender una sola cosa y
especializarnos en una sola cosa
realizando ejercicios repetitivos
memorizando datos aprendiendo a seguir
órdenes
y compitiendo entre nosotros prometiendo
no es una calificación o un mejor
trabajo pero hoy existe alguien que
ama el trabajo especializado
que es excelente repitiendo tareas
es predecible y estupendo en el manejo
de datos obedece ciegamente no cobra y
descansa
quién es ese
la inteligencia artificial
entonces todos estos trabajos
especializados repetitivos de manejo de
datos y siguieron es
están desapareciendo tenemos miedo de
que las computadoras tomen nuestros
trabajos y con razón hay estudios que
dicen que entre el 40 y 50 por ciento de
los trabajos como los conocemos van a
desaparecer en los próximos 10 años y
muchos de ellos van a ser tomados por la
inteligencia artificial
y estamos compitiendo con inteligencia
artificial para ganarle
pero no estamos diseñados para eso
tenemos un poco de estudiar nuestro cómo
funcionamos nuestro cerebro humano
realmente poco más de 100 años pero
dentro de lo que sabemos sabemos que
nosotros como humanos nuestro cerebro
número 1 somos buenos cruzando cosas se
nos da
si ustedes se fijan los ganadores de
premios nobel no es gente que se
especializará en una sola cosa sino que
agarraron diferentes disciplinas y las
combinaron para crear algo novedoso e
innovador para el mundo
eso no lo pueden hacer las máquinas
somos buenos manejando lo impredecible
cuando algo no sucede cuando lo
esperábamos somos buenos para inventar y
para crear para tener una solución
creativa y encontrar una solución a un
problema no esperado las computadoras
las las máquinas no pueden si algo no
pasa exactamente como se esperaba la
máquina a lo grande se bloquea
otra cosa es que necesitamos emociones
para aprender no hay nada malo en
memorizar datos y en memorizar
información pero tenemos un límite y
además necesitamos emociones para
aprender una vez que vinculamos un
conocimiento con una emoción nunca se
nos olvida porque cuando tenemos
emociones como la sorpresa o como la
alegría generamos dopamina y la dopamina
ayuda a asimilar esas emociones y esos
conocimientos por eso nunca se nos
olvidan pero también nos ayuda a
relacionarnos con los demás tenemos una
cosa chistosa que se llama pensamiento
crítico que aunque sabemos las reglas
aunque sabemos lo que hay que hacer de
repente como que nos dan ganas de no
seguirlas como que nos pensamos si
hubiera una mejor forma de hacerlo o si
hubiera una mejor forma de realizar las
tareas aquí en méxico decimos que pues
la cosa es como buscarle
y una cosa más somos complementarios los
estudios
de la inteligencia humana evidencian que
tenemos diferentes formas de aprender y
de entender el mundo tenemos diferentes
inteligencias cada uno de nosotros hay
quien es genético hay quien es abstracto
ahí tienes matemático de quien es
musical de tal forma que cuando
trabajamos en equipo
cada uno aporta algo único que los demás
no pueden cuando cuando los seres
humanos trabajamos nos sumamos
multiplicamos las computadoras suman
nosotros multiplicamos es como si
estuviéramos diseñados para colaborar
según un estudio del foro económico
mundial del futuro de los trabajos de
aquí al 2030 las competencias que van a
ser más buscadas en el 2022 son las
siguientes las 5 más buscadas crear
ideas nuevas
y resolver problemas no predecibles
comprender emociones de los demás el
pensamiento crítico tal cual
y complementarse con otros 103 son estas
hay muchas competencias pudiéramos
hablar de muchas no como las primeras
diez y estas yo lo resumiría en 21 la
capacidad de colaborar con otros y dos
el pensamiento crítico es decir la
capacidad de poder formular las
preguntas correctas como saben que esas
son las competencias porque no sabemos
cómo va a ser el mundo del mañana es
imposible predecir cuál va a ser la
tecnología cuál va a ser el avance la
nueva plataforma la nueva tendencia que
va a cambiar el mundo es imposible
predecirlo pero si sabemos cómo va a ser
el humano del futuro
así
esas competencias nunca van a pasar de
moda
las usaron los exploradores cuando
descubrieron otras partes del mundo
la solución a eagle para encontrar una
solución en parís hoy las necesitamos
para tener acceso a las oportunidades de
la del mundo de la nueva era de la
globalización porque hoy estamos en la
cuarta revolución industrial ya la
tercera ya se acabó la cuarta revolución
es el internet de las cosas los mismos
celulares que ustedes traen en este
momento están recabando información de
todos nosotros es saben lo que vivimos
nuestros gustos a donde fuimos aquel
lugar hemos hemos asistido cuánto tiempo
vamos a durar en esta plática entonces
qué sentido tiene competir con las
computadoras cuando estamos diseñados
para otra cosa
de repente tenemos miedo que las
máquinas tomen nuestro lugar
pero
y si las computadoras fueran la clave de
una nueva era de los humanos
haciendo las labores mecanizadas
repetitivas de obediencia ciega
y dejándonos tiempo libre para responder
las preguntas que son importantes para
nosotros como raza como especie
como protegemos al que lo necesita como
creamos condiciones dignas de vida para
todos que consideras justo
se necesitan humanos para responder a
esas preguntas
y las competencias que desarrollamos hoy
para poder acceder a la redistribución
global de la riqueza en la cuarta
revolución industrial de la nueva era de
la globalización son las mismas que nos
hacen mejores seres humanos es decir la
competencia de empatía para poder
desarrollar una solución para un cliente
de una empresa es la misma empatía que
necesitas para entender un problema de
tu vecino la capacidad de trabajo en
equipo de resolución de conflictos que
puedes aplicar a un proyecto de una
multinacional es la misma capacidad que
puedes usar para trabajar con los
vecinos de tu colonia para mejorar una
parte de su vecindario
pero yo les pregunto a ustedes les han
enseñado estas competencias porque a mí
no
como las desarrollamos estas
competencias no pueden aprenderse en el
aula no salen de un libro no salen de un
método se aprenden haciéndolas les
quiero compartir tres formas de
desarrollar nuestras competencias número
1 participen en actividades por su
comunidad integre se en actividades para
mejorar su colonia para mejorar sociedad
donde puedan desarrollar trabajo con
otros número 2 siempre tengan una mente
abierta para aprender siempre tengan una
actitud de aprendizaje durante toda su
vida
tiene sentido no dejar de aprender
porque la vida nunca deja de enseñar
y 3 a gales como nadie el viaje
sean voluntarios nacionales
internacionales integren se en programas
en donde puedan trabajar junto con una
persona de francia de italia holanda
dinamarca corea-japón aprendan cómo ven
el mundo de ellos aprendan cómo
resuelven problemas como conceptualizar
una situación conflictiva y como
reaccionan entre ella y compartan lo
suyo
eso se llama aprendizaje intercultural y
es un componente fundamental para el
desarrollo de competencias decíamos que
tenemos miedo no miedo pero ansiedad del
futuro
imaginen un mundo en donde dejemos de
competir con las computadoras con las
máquinas y nos diferenciamos de ellas
desarrollando nuestras competencias
haciendo lo que nos hace ser mejores
seres humanos mejor especie para este
planeta y en dónde
complicamos más completamos menos perdón
y colaboremos más
y escuchemos para comprender
en lugar de escuchar para responder
desarrollemos la empatía con nuestro
prójimo con nuestro planeta con nuestro
medio ambiente con las especies con las
que compartimos este planeta
desarrollamos nuestra capacidad en
equipo para encontrar las soluciones de
las cosas que nos afectan a todos y
ponemos a las máquinas a trabajar para
eso pero entre nosotros construir el
mundo que todos queremos y que todos
merecemos ese ser un mundo
más empático más incluyente más justo y
más amoroso para todos y en ese mundo
que cercano y que brillante sería el
futuro
y esa es una idea valiosa para compartir
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]